all right guys happy tuesday we've got
clear skies out there i do see just
barely a little bit of wildfire smoke
just barely still going to be in the
good category so kiddos heading back to
school boy you had a three-day weekend
staff development day yesterday 77 right
now oh it feels good outside with that
dry air but
make sure you're drinking lots of water
because that dry air is going to
dehydrate you 102 gonna be another hot
one this afternoon so love the 70s that
are showing up and by the weekend a lot
of neighborhoods are going to have 60s
as we start to cool down well we're
catching up with tropical storm nicholas
came ashore overnight as a category 1
hurricane across the texas coast
houston has been spared a blow as this
storm is starting to turn right and pull
the rain out with it but galveston
corpus christi those areas not doing too
well they've racked up almost 14 inches
of rain along the gulf coast this is a
live shot right now from galveston and
you can see the bay is still
battering with us some big waves there
they're getting 30 40 mile-per-hour
winds right now people driving around in
the in the rain there are nearly six
million people under flash flood alerts
across the southern louisiana area
southeast texas all these areas of green
so a lot of people still at flood risk
and it could be life-threatening at
times there's so much rain left with
tropical storm nicholas as it rolls east
into southern louisiana people still
trying to clean up from getting ravaged
by ida a couple of weeks ago we'll be
dry we'll be sunny we'll be hot today
102
we should be right around 95 degrees
yeah instead we're looking at triple
digits for a couple of days breezy winds
thursday and then the 90s start showing
up and they'll last all the way through
the weekend into next week here come the
60s for morning lows that's going to
feel oh so good a lot of folks are ready
for some cooler temperatures